[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean-luc aujourd'hui quel bonheur de
retrouver cette chronique en prime time
et mon jean luc je crois que tu t'es tu
t'es pencher sur tout ce qui s'est passé
dans cette émission
oui j'ai vu ça de manière un peu
différente de vous parce que j'ai des
images que je ne vous avais pas vus à et
ces gens pas été diffusée et qui donne
un autre éclairage vous allez voir aller
une question qu'à une question
aujourd'hui que tu as bien sûr il ya
bonjour je m'appelle christina ce soir
tout le monde a été gâté sauf moi donc
je voulais savoir s'il n'est pas trop
fatigué est-ce que syrie pourrait venir
visiter ma cheminée
[Applaudissements]
christina malheureusement il ne peut pas
il a déjà assez de problèmes et que le
csa comme ça auriez vous enverra un
cadeau par la poste comme tout le monde
déjà beaucoup donné pour le petit cube
on l'a vu tout à l'heure où hugo il est
toujours là bas un logo pour le rêve
était d'aller voir un match de lyon
ouais et le cauchemar de cyril de porter
un maillot de l'olympique lyonnais ce
qu'il appelle lui-même dans son langage
fleuri une race rats les gars préparer
le maillot de paris quand le must de
paris va arriver bonsoir je ne sois pas
dans la merde quoi j'ai en fait le
manteau pour le psg bonjour moi je suis
pour tout vous l'avez dit tu t'es là
d'ailleurs quand vous parlez de l'om de
guingamp j'ai eu un message d'ailleurs
de sylvain armand de règne que
j'embrasse mon silva voilà qu'ils vous
regardent ce soir et vous avez dit quoi
tout à l'heure que venait pas je n'ai
pas de religion sportive d'accord en
fait il était vraiment panique mais
heureusement une responsable de la
communication de lyon va lui glissé une
phrase magique et là vous allez voir ça
va tout changer
la prochaine fois que j'allais au parc
vont me foute dehors
ça va se faire siffler c'est obligé on
n'ira pas de l'année
un bravo bravo dire gvg je n'ai pas
écoutez moi bien je n'ai pas de religion
sportive
je vais la fac à toi je vais la faire
cuire tout de suite ce alors j'adore
je kiffe l'om je kiffe leurs études mais
je n'ai pas de religion de sport je
kiffe tout le monde oui
alors
m
je le relis je pouvais pas lutter je
demandais à loïc le faire voilà j'ai
travaillé avec moi qui m'en vois tous
les chiffres d'ailleurs et que
j'embrasse port mon lolo et sur twitter
merci à toute cette communauté voilà
j'étais embrassera à 8 ans je n'ai pas
de religion reste vive le sport
les oublis vive la france mais si on y
était là le problème c'est qu'après
cyril a passé sa soirée à serrer des
mains et a répété qu'il n'avait pas de
religion aussi se présenter aux
primaires du football
le plus beau c'est quand il était reçu
son plateau doit les tv avec marc
lavoine
on sent que le discours de campagne le
ciri marque c'est pas son truc
[Musique]
merci à l'ol de m'inviter et voilà et
avantias j'avais le maillot du psg avant
avant-hier j'avais le maillot de
guingamp je n'ai pas de religion
sportive j'aime le sport j'ai le maillot
de l'om chez tous les vaio x et dont
beaucoup impliqués petit hugo et de sa
famille qu avec un c'est sympa ça c'est
quand ils s'investissent investi à fond
en plus il a une mémoire infaillible
donc comme il avait vu une photo du
petit hugo
il a tout de suite reconnu grand frère
du go tell grand frère voter non le
cousin comment tu t'appelles tu es beau
aussi l'apec où elles sont claires tout
cola
[Musique]
mais douze ans s'est passé mais c'est
pas tout ses toiles sont prêts
[Applaudissements]
ouais
parce que dans ma tête ça depuis le
début ce qu'ils sont mais vous l'avez
dit en fait que c'était son frère jean
pierre foucault vous vous souvenez ça
c'est pas de sa faute à cyril 1 c'est
normal quand tu croises beaucoup de gens
étaient un peu perdus dans ce but quand
tu es au parc ol et que tu te rend même
plus compte que tu dis bonjour la même
personne trois fois de suite
je te remercie servient super deçà il
assiste à la merci merci merci
un truc à manger pas partir comme au
temps de jeu ce qu'ils n'avaient plus à
simon commerciaux oui alala les mauvais
soir parce que le mec en fait m'a suivi
partout face à chamalières otage je
voyais pour gérer comme il s'occupait de
l'écuyer j'avais un petit peu fin
c'était votre ami à ce moment-là glisser
des trucs à manger aux fêtes sur tout le
parcours mais en syrie il a été très
gentil et patient avec tout le monde et
en plus il avait donné une petite
surprise pour tout le monde ça va
bonjour ça va bien ça va et vous battre
à rien
en fait il transporte sa série trop en
faire en fait l égard garder c'est ici
qu'ils transportent et noir ont surpris
tout à l'heure il est étendu j'avais en
effet rires cela dans le match oui et
n'aura eu la pudeur de participent à des
magnétos sans se montrer elle restée
dans sa caisse avec les enfants qu'il
gardait moctar bah il est plein de
questions à poser sur la jolie petite
bretonne je m'en fous vérité vérité est
ce que c'est vrai qu'une or elle est
belle sans maquillage
non je vais pas te dire comment il est
tout petit mois n'avoir pas en fait je
n'arrive pas à l'avant à pau
il esquive série qui se déroule album tu
as donc gillon la vie au tout début
c'était le stage commando
bon on n'a pas pu tout montrer mais il a
vraiment souffert notamment quand sur
grenade il a posé dans une rivière gelée
ce climat du moment où il a essayé de se
réchauffer je suis désolé j veu
nettement avec la serviette
j'étais tout de suite reconnu sa
carrière à leur père j ouer toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le gars désole gilles un bon gta
sa personne c'est le même discours la
choisit gilles 1
parce que c'était le seul à pouvoir le
faire pas du du moelleux par les airs
c'est ce qui expliquait à florian
regardez il ya que moi qui pouvais faire
ça non mais je ne parlais pas
franchement j'aurais pas mis un sou sur
sorte aux années l'udc c'est vrai
j'aurais parié sur qui dans le mode
d'aventuriers peut-être matt de louis ii
tout ça va mais c'est un vrai malfrat
je vais te démonter sa tente c'est la
tienne aussi déconne pas vrai mais il
est ne laissait rien faire quand
j'écoute sont permanents et d'un
physique quand même visible de quoi
aller les couilles lesquels les casseurs
comme mec quand on dirait qu'elle met le
pack --- d'occasion à quatre occasions
sur ebay ou je sais pas quoi la mer
desquels la moindre difficulté les trous
mais à bauma jamais comme sa courbe est
apparemment de des fenêtres voilà à
dents et finit le temps chez noir est
nombreux je pense qu'elle aurait été way
mode aventure hier je pensais
alors effet peut-être elle tord est
vraiment casser les couilles je pense
aussi j'avais cassé les couilles tu
crois que si ça doit rester ou pas cyril
non non je crois pas qu'il ait un peu
tout ce qu'ils trouvaient que c'était
les fans et ils s'emmerdent vite en
place non s'il a peu de wifi les perdu
que ouais non non ça l'aurait pas fait
enfin franchement tu étais un des
animateurs
voilà que j'aime pas spécialement
carrelage pas pu te ferai ce que je te
dirai pas non plus de l'émission mais
lorsque tu as ta place et et
d'intervention sont sont perspicaces
mais je sais pas il y avait un truc qui
passait pas je passais faciès physique
je te trouvais un peu hautain mais tu
prenais les gens des fois un peu de haut
et à dire côté de clichés non mais ouais
mais mais là franchement là c'est cette
journée qu'on a passées dans la salle
daniel conus les autres gagnent pas être
connu
[Applaudissements]
alors on a appris deux choses les autres
ne gagnent pas être connu et cyril il
est un peu toutoune côté petit schwytz
et moi bah ne s'est pas l'oeil à
personne de l'autre côté je pense que
c'est pas ça alors c'est quoi toutoune
et de sa flore et bêtes bébête
ah non c'est pas ça c'est quoi tu
tournes de toni kroos qua non non non
non tenues quoi oui justin son port non
mais vous en faites vous voyez le
maintenant nous noyer signe c'est ça un
peu tout à noter que moi surtout ce
concept est fragile
voilà il faut pas capable de se
stabiliser pas capable de faire ça non
ces petites choses un peu grasse et non
celui qui l'a dit merci bon je vais je
suis obligé d'être honnête gilles a dit
calme à florian qui avait un chroniqueur
avec qui ça aurait vraiment fait
quelqu'un de remarquable
d'après vous c'est qui benjamin non
remarquables luc hallé non il ya là je
pense que tu aurais pu là qui fait parce
que je pense que quand je vais me dire
son nom
tu vas me dire non pas elle sait benhaim
voilà nom havana ah ouais ouais ouais
ouais
ah ouais base images il m'a dit non mais
c'est vrai qu'elle ne porte pas sur elle
ne passe pas du tout sur el aouel ne
porte pas sur qu'est-ce qu'elle porte
sur elle
qu'est ce que ça va tu étonné bah ouais
zidi moi ce que c'est la plus chaude
beinheim beinheim et je sais même pas ce
temps a pu finir l'année avec elle et la
coque elle ne porte pas le nom il va
tomber amoureux chine
la corvée live
non mais vous voulez et vous laisse
chauffer voilà ce soit les droites
droite comme une formule 1 voilà mais
d'après gilles valérie et chaude à koh
lanta juste en se déshabillant elle
allume le feu en deux secondes
bon c'était trop dangereux de mettre
dans les bois non l on l'a fait sauter
en parachute avec ses nouvelles copines
on sent plus grand plaisir et fit
d'ailleurs tellement contente que si
elle est pensée elle
non mais franchement en vrai en vrai
cyril il le fait c'est son idée il le
fait il est où là non mais un cadeau bas
mais alors pourquoi ces poissons qu'elle
doit cyril tiens il va faire quoi lui
dans l'émission tu vas me dire un truc
hyper cool hyper simple où il aura juste
à faire un os avaler cheryl et chérie et
passe à côté du cdh elio l'asile dire
savez c'est de dire des choses pareilles
c'est dégueulasse ou pas je te rappelle
que si elle a fait un cadeau très très
risqué
bah oui la camair regarder un match de
foot dans une loge du vent du champagne
avec un milieu de l'ol fait le dos alors
qu'il n'ya pas de religion sportive pas
compte du risque
[Applaudissements]
elle m'a appelé après le mar merci c'est
vrai d'abord je vous ai appelé pour vous
insultez mois et ensuite dans un
l'agepar et produit après la bombe avait
fait le saut avec les copines on s'est
éclaté je les embrasse encore une fois
parce que je les adore et j'ai vraiment
je suis passé en un dixième de seconde
de la peur la plus extrême au bonheur le
plus incroyable vraiment je rassure je
rassure et après c'est calme et assez
calmes et elle a fait une très belle
promesse que je propose de voir et là je
fais avec toi mais c'est pas sûr que je
un grand pas depuis quand le derrière de
cyril hanouna quand je vais le voir ça
c'est oui mais elle rend pas pour
l'avenir je pense que vous rêvez voir
enfin le premier tu vas voir ça écoute
moi bien sûr le plateau quand on
reviendra
je te promets que je lui colle un coup
de pied au cul abel accord est une
goutte d'eau au regard des passagers
généreux 1908
[Applaudissements]
allez est patent que tous ces moments où
j'ai me valérie non mais j'ai voulu vous
frappée très violemment
imaginez en fait j'ai vraiment avec un
moment incroyable vraiment les joues pas
semblé vous voulez faire un bisou quand
même nom a même passé si vous voulez
faut patiemment bien manager la
chouannerie oui à mal ah oui c'est vrai
il est où tous nos travers regardez ce
combat à mener pour moi je vais quand
même sauvé la journée savez il devait
geler love coach à l'appel dans le
métier une fbi est une fausse bonne idée
vos conseils pendant le speed dating
avec pierrick et réussi à obtenir une
réponse positive sur cinq honnêtement
c'est un miracle mais oui à sa décharge
jean michel était pas très concentré cas
pour le tournage
il pensait déjà au près mais suivant ses
envies qu'on va tourner au ski n'est ce
pas un show with jay passage pas prévu
pour l'instant se fout de tout ça
faudrait qu'on ne sent rien à chaque
voyage amer fromages savoyards
qui prépare la baisse
tout va bien
et à chaque fois c'est à dire que tu
comparais de n'importe quoi les repas de
fondue savoyarde quand même
et le mec réussi à recadrer quand même
assez l'autoroute
je ne sais pas ce qui lui passe bien et
ça va jean-michel nos régions ont du
talent
[Applaudissements]
et on arrive aux cadeaux qui s'occupait
donc de 8 enfants évidemment très
méritante on l'a vu tout à l'heure
angélique on s'est dit qu'on adore parce
que c'est une maman modèle mais aussi
parce qu'ils ne ratent pas une émission
ne touche pas à mon poste dont quelques
des biens tous les chroniqueurs et quand
on lui demande qui n'auraient pas pu
s'occuper des enfants
un avis très tranché alors elle et les
pires chroniqueur que j'aurais pu
recevoir à la maison je pense que ça
aurait été gilles verdez je vois
incapable de s'occuper de lui enfant
déborder tout fille ouais je le vois pas
du tout dans dans ce rôle là et
de leurs maux alors oui je le voyais
bien joué dans la voiture de mon fils et
puis c'est tout les gamins on verra
après elle a vu juste
et très clairvoyant plus angélique et
surtout elle a un avis sur tout
angélique elle est là bas la honte je
crois parce que franchement quand il
raconte tout était pmp c'est un bonheur
enfin sa bonne en mai mais pas pour tout
le monde
[Musique]
ah c'est vrai que mokhtar et cyril
hanouna nous à la maison c'est les deux
chouchous quoi franchement motards mans
il m'a fait rire le tee shirt avec le
chat la à las vegas moi ça restera gravé
après j'adore cyril hanouna
bon après j'aime aussi benhaim par
contre de l'ormeau voulait pas trop de
cerfs-volants
là franchement de leurs mots je n'aime
pas trop et cela se faire on dirait
qu'ils aiment ça en fait un endroit un
peu pour un con et l'homme ça comment
s'appelle moi je les adore aussi cette
femme à la des buts de reuille toujours
bizarroïde eu ces mots ni ribes
je sais pas dire ce moment est trop
compliqué isabelle voilà est elle aussi
j'aime beaucoup j'adore quand elle la
côte qui se moque
j'adore alors mon chouchou aussi moi je
les adore c'est jean michel maire
j'aimerais des fois que cyril hanouna
lui [ __ ] la paix 1 même s'il frappe de
satom jean michel maire je trouve que
c'est un bel homme et je sais pas
pourquoi je sais pas est ce que c'est
physique est ce que c'est dans son
comportement de comment il parle comment
on le rabaisse aussi cette ça m'énerve
savoir en tirer du diable on passe à
autre chose je crie derrière ma télé
mais tim maeyens a parlé oui
après thierry moreau bon pas plus que ça
alors gilles verdez alors lui mais il me
tape sur le système
j'ai bien rigolé quand il s'était pris
là-bas c'est pas c'est pas rigolo parce
que j'aurais pu lui être à sa place mais
mais je le pense
donc j'ai rigolé quand il s'est pris
là-bas après enora bon voilà c'est une
aura rien à dire dessus
moi ça ne me dérange pas forcément que
jean michel maire parle de ça voilà moi
je suis tout le temps en train de parler
de mes enfants bon vous allez me dire
c'est pas pareil mais mais c'est son
truc à lui c'est sa personnalité et puis
toute façon c'est là que tout plateau et
est en train de rire a donc
oui certainement très obsédé mais bon
souvent c'est ceux qui en parlent le
plus qui en font moins
tu es excepte le lait l'angélique jeu
l'accord allait trop drôle ça va les
enfants vous allez rater avec des
cadeaux jean-luc c'était formidable
comme d'habitude jean luc lemoine pour
l'état
[Applaudissements]